first it was called the watergate caper
it was 50 years ago this weekend the
most famous break-in in american history
that led to its most consequential
scandal people have got to know whether
or not their president is a crook
well i'm not a crook
five men were arrested for trying to bug
the watergate complex site of democratic
national committee headquarters the
watergate affair began to look less
minor when along with the five two other
men were indicted the members of the
so-called white house plumbers used
chapstick tubes containing tiny
microphones and communicated via
walkie-talkies and transistor radios
a cover-up began immediately
as did news coverage if any or all of
what is alleged to have been going on is
true how high up in the white house does
it go by may 1973
televised hearings transfixed the nation
i regret that i must today name others
who participated with me in the
watergate affair
president nixon eventually fired the
special prosecutor in the case but that
didn't stop more indictments the basic
question at issue today
is whether the president personally
acted improperly in the watergate matter
formal impeachment proceedings against
nixon began in may
1974
and facing almost certain removal from
office the president resigned that
august we leave
with high hopes
in good spirit
and with deep humility
you can learn more about the watergate
scandal the break in its aftermath and
its impact on american history and the
cbs special watergate high crimes in the
white house it is available to stream
now on
paramount plus interesting to look back
for those who don't especially right now
yeah and right now what is going on in
our world